Donald Trump has an economic advisor
named Larry Kudlow Larry Kudlow is a
right winger he occasionally will say
something uncontroversial that just kind
of makes sense but very often Larry
Kudlow says outrageous things that don't
make any sense Larry Kudlow also used to
have an addiction problem with both
cocaine and alcohol and there have been
a number of recent appearances where it
has been speculated that Kudlow seems
drunk Kudlow recently appeared on CNBC
he of course downplayed virus fears and
suggested during the interview that
America stay at work he also sounded
completely drunk as if Donald Trump and
Mike Pence being clueless on this issue
was not bad enough alone here's Larry
Kudlow listen to him slurring seems to
pause a few times to burp it's a very
strange video well I'm not sure where
you're going on that look immediately in
January against the advice of a lot of
health professionals President Trump
automatically put on travel bans with
respect to China and then we instituted
quarantines for the people Americans
coming back from China and foreign
nationals it continues to get worse
Kudlow number one making no sense but
number two sounding impaired here he is
saying America should stay at work if
you're healthy you should go to work go
batshit business that's our advice and
even regarding transportation you know
which maybe hit the airlines and they
were very calm about it but they're in
trouble and some of their numbers look
domestic flight for the most part is in
good shape and if you stay away from
some of the travel warning countries
international flight likewise so I don't
want to downplay anything we worried
about the effect on human
but I'm just saying that's not over in
any way here that Larry but shot of the
day at work
we should stay at work and then as the
interview continues just sounding more
and more slurry
although slurry is something else slur
like maybe is a better term help
professions that I speak to Scott
Gottlieb the former FDA Commissioner
would say very different things in
particular about Seattle and about the
government response that needs to
actually take place and how we need to
be a lot more formidable in our response
and statements like the ones you just
actually bring the encouraging people
got to do things that they shouldn't and
that will actually cause the spread of
the virus as opposed to it stop it I
don't look Scott ghoul is a brain guy
and he's friend of mine with respect to
Seattle all right that would be a place
you would avoid for now and gavin newsom
governor Newsom declaring a California
emergency state vest in Northern
California I understand that avoid
listen Scott God leaves a friend of mine
I respect the guy this does not sound
normal ladies and gentlemen it is very
strange stuff and I have to tell you I'm
all in favor of the do not panic type of
stuff panic on top of whatever the facts
are it never makes a situation better
there's no question about that and again
I believe the death rate is far lower
than what is being reported for the
United States for Post February one
cases I believe there are likely tons of
people that aren't even in the numbers
who are having super mild cases of the
virus the problem is that with this
administration it's don't panic we don't
have any cases and then we get cases so
then they have to say well listen don't
panic we haven't had any deaths because
we're so prepared and then we get deaths
and then it's don't panic we have very
few new cases and then yesterday we had
more new cases than China which
increasingly seems to have it under
control and is dropping the number of
active cases by one to two thousand
every single day then it's don't panic
we have the tests but we actually don't
have the tests they simply
can't be believed about any of this
period and so when Larry Kudlow shows up
sounding drunk seeming impaired and says
well I think we should probably stay at
work and you know this is all overblown
and the president knows what he's doing
and pens no no they don't know what
they're doing Mike Pence who tried to
pray when he was dealing with an HIV
crisis in his state of Indiana is the
guy that's running this entire thing and
by the way we learned over the weekend
that so CPAC was last week or the week
before there was an attendee at CPAC who
shook hands with Matt slap that attendee
has the virus Matt slap then shook hands
and was on stage for a while with both
Trump and pence now the timing of it
does not suggest that they were infected
Ted Cruz was also involved in that
Ted Cruz says out of an abundance of
caution he is self quarantine until a
full 14 days have passed since that
handshake an event took place is it
possible that as it encroaches on them
they will take it more seriously and it
you know it's sort of like when you have
an anti-gay politician that changes
their mind when they find out their kid
is gay and we say well they came around
to the right position but it's really a
startling lack of empathy that they were
only able to change their mind
when it affected them rather than being
able to say well let me imagine what it
would be like if I had a gay kid right
or a kid who's part of the LGBT
community in much the same way it would
be great whatever causes this
administration to start taking this
seriously it's sad because of the lack
of empathy that it confirms that it
depends on Trump and pence shaking hands
with someone that was exposed to
somebody carrying the virus and or of
course the idea that Trump realizes this
might have a political implication I'd
better get it together it's sad but if
that's what it takes to get them to take
it seriously I'll still accept it one of
our sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch
don't pay thousands of dollars for a
high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of inch
arrows watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even chera watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether in
silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get 15%
off inch arrows entire collection when
you go to david pakman.com slash watch